they survived the earthquakes but now
they're eager to save what's left in
nurudai
[Music]
they will have to rebuild their lives
and everything matters
we called you to take out your
belongings the municipality worker says
brother his phone was under the rubble
how are you going to reach them
it took a lifetime to accumulate what
people had
it was taken away in a matter of minutes
our belonging things I wish all of this
was gone so I didn't have to care about
it
from one of the shops they Salvage what
they can
we're not looters we're not looters
they're our own Goods they say
we will try to survive all we have is
lost
what the state or people will give us in
Aid will only last a week and then we'll
be hungry we have children we must
survive and what we built in the last 30
years is gone we had three houses and
now we're in a tent like
the search continues
even at this stage some cling onto hope
as everyone Falls silent
Rescuers use their equipment to search
for any sign of life
the earthquakes took away lives and
homes but some things can't be taken
we lost everything I took some pages of
the Quran out only memories left nothing
else is left it's all gone behind this
was my shop all the families are gone
a page of the Quran lies in the Box in
front of a tent
the mutual rivalry of this world diverts
you until you visit the graves the
verses say
too many this city is now a graveyard
as
Southern turkey